hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another video usually needs videos I
talk about famous entrepreneurs and the
lessons that you can learn from their
success today I'm gonna take a slightly
different approach and I'm going to talk
about my iPad I just came back from a
vacation and I use my iPad as my main
computing device instead of bringing my
computer and it save might be patient I
want to talk about all the different
ways that I used it and hopefully tell
you about a couple apps that you haven't
heard of and how you might be able to
use it for your next trip as well so
here we go app number one DJ or iPod
driving from Toronto to New York is
about a nine hour trip depending on
delays at the border
they can get really boring if you don't
have music my wife and I have a
tradition of making a new CD full of
songs every time we travel unfortunately
once we crossing the Buffalo we stopped
at a Plaza and I loved the car lights on
I killed our battery we got a new
battery installed that our stereo system
has an anti-theft mechanism that if you
change the battery the stereo gets
disabled unless you have the unlock code
we didn't have an honest which meant no
music for the rest of our trip enter DJ
or iPod luckily I had loaded my songs
onto my iPad as well before we left we
had music for the rest of our trip the
iPad batteries were awesome and the
speaker was pretty good in the car we
found the best spot to put the iPad was
in the Sun Visor with a speaker pointing
down I bought the DJ app because I'm
also a salsa DJ in my part time it's the
best app I know that I've seen for
mixing songs and hosting parties but the
native iPod app would have done the
trick just as well and it's free
app number two evernote evernote is a
cool tool that lets you store notes and
pictures online and access them from any
device i've used in the past to go
paperless and get rid of all my paper
receipts and after watch the video on
youtube I never really use it for
anything beyond keeping track of my
receipts but this vacation provided a
perfect opportunity to test it out
before going away I loaded my desktop
version of Evernote with information on
each city that would be visited I put in
places we should visit information about
where we would be docking and a little
bit of history about the city it
automatically synced with my Evernote
app on my iPad and whenever we landed in
a new city I had all the information at
my fingertips the basic app is free but
if you want to be able to have the
information available offline then you
need to upgrade for $4.99 a month of
$44.99 in a year I know some
entrepreneurs who store every idea they
have on Evernote and use it as an
integral part of their business I'll
definitely be looking at other ways to
incorporate it into my daily life after
the great experience from this trip app
number three
sleep pillow my son is a little over two
years old and is used to sleeping with
the sound machine that helps drown out
any background noise unfortunately in
our haste to leave
we forgot his sound machine at home
there must be an app for that
enter sleep pillow with this app you can
choose from a large selection of sounds
to help you fall asleep from water
falling the chimes to spa music our
favorite was the electric fan it were
like a charm and when you're traveling
with the two-year-old nothing beats a
good night's sleep
app number four male when you're
traveling on a cruise ship connecting to
the Internet can cost upwards of $1 per
minute in the past my wife and I would
connect using Microsoft Outlook download
our emails disconnect respond to the
emails reconnect and send so we're not
spending hundreds of dollars on slow
cruise ship Wi-Fi this time I took a
different approach I connected my email
to my iPad and when we landed in a new
city would find a local Starbucks and
connect to download my email after
dinner back onboard the ship
I would load up the emails respond and
the next day connect again in a new city
to send the emails and download new ones
it was unbelievably freeing to not have
to load my laptop to get my emails and
to be able to reply at my leisure op
number-five Instapaper and Zeit usually
when I go on vacation I packed a lot of
books and magazines as reading material
this time my goal was to pack everything
I needed for the entire two-week trip in
one backpack and carry it with me books
and magazines are heavy so they couldn't
come with me
enter Instapaper Instapaper was after
the first app I bought when I got my
iPad what did it allows you to do is
clip articles that you read online and
save them to read offline later you can
install a little button on your browser
and whenever you see something that you
want to read but don't have the time yet
click the button it'll save it and you
can read it offline on your iPad
whenever you want I get a lot of my
reading material from the RSS feeds that
I subscribe to in Google Reader and
instapaper has built-in intelligence to
work with Google Reader so it's a
seamless process I also get my news from
site which is free which has instant
paper integration as part of my daily
routine in Toronto I'll go through my
Google Reader and Zeit while I eat
breakfast and save anything that's
interesting the instant paper then I'll
read it on my iPad as I walk to and from
work before leaving on this trip I
loaded up my instant paper with lots of
reading material from blogs that I
follow and when I connected to send
emails I often loaded up my site to save
any interesting articles as well it gave
me lots of reading material to go
through offline while relaxing on a deck
chair on the cruise ship and be carrying
around heavy books and magazines with me
everywhere
app number six interactive ebooks for
kids for those of you who travel with
kids I would definitely recommend
checking out some of the interactive
ebooks you can install on your iPad we
don't let our son watch TV yep and we
didn't have space to bring all his books
so I downloaded a number of e-books that
he thoroughly enjoyed while we were away
they were educational and also a great
way to calm him down when he was getting
too tired or worked up there are many
options out there but you have to sort
through them to find the good ones that
are age-appropriate my two-year-old
son's favorites were the monster at the
end of the book Thomas and Friends
Mickey spooky night puzzle book and the
Lorax for dr. Seuss they're all teach
reading skills and interactive and allow
your kids to explore books in a whole
new way as well as give their parents
some time to relax
up number seven maps when traveling in
the past I used to get a map of each
place we were visiting research all the
spots I wanted to visit and mark them on
a map the map would usually start to
wear down on me with all the folding and
unfolding throughout the course of the
day if we wanted to find something that
I didn't mark on the map we had to ask
the locals and hope they gave us the
right directions entered the native Maps
app maps is automatically installed on
your iPad and saved me so many times on
this trip it can automatically detect
where you are in a city and you can
quickly see where you have to go seen it
on the big screen was so much more
helpful than on the iPhone especially
when you're in a city as big as New York
and you want to cover a lot of territory
we use it to plan our subway routes look
up sushi restaurants see how far away we
were from our car find our cruise ship
and the list went on my favorite use was
when I was shopping in a drugstore in
New York City and a grandmother with her
baby grandchild asked me if there was a
Walgreens anywhere nearby my Toronto
Blue Jays hat didn't tip her off that I
was in a local I pulled up my iPad
searched Walgreens and maps and showed
her that there was one two blocks away
and how to get there she was floored and
it made her day number eight
GarageBand I purposely removed any games
I had on my iPad I tried many of them
out for a month and found them to be
overly addictive and counterproductive
better to delete them completely and not
be tempted but I found myself sometimes
wanting to have some fun in my downtime
instead of reading enter garage read I
started using GarageBand when YouTube
was giving me issues with having
background music in my videos even
though I had the rights to use the music
I'm currently uploading about 5 videos
per week on my youtube channel and each
one of them was a battle with YouTube of
the music rights so I decided to create
my own music and I use GarageBand to do
it the music you hear in the background
of this video was created by me in brush
man so when I found myself wanting to
have a little more fun I cranked open
GarageBand and started composing with
earphones on so it's not the disturbed
rest of my family
it's a great way to kill boredom but do
something in that somewhat practical
instead of playing games at least that's
what I told myself in conclusion the
trip was made so much easier and more
enjoyable because of the iPad we had
music we could travel lightly we could
sleep we knew where we were going and we
had a lot more fun being able to travel
without having used my computer was so
liberating
I can't imagine ever going back and
can't wait for my next trip thank you
for joining me for another video if you
guys liked it please give it a thumbs up
below I'd also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment under the video and stay
tuned for the next episode
you